women
do you think that women can be happy
without children
but yeah I think I think they can be
happy I know lots of women that put
their career first nowadays and I think
a lot of people kind of underestimate
how much a child will change your life
because it's not something that goes
away like if you want to go out for
dinner or all the things you can do when
you're
by yourself without a child you can't do
them you always have to have child care
you know it costs a lot of money Child
Care is very expensive
um and there's always stress there's
always the worry of is my child healthy
is my child safe and I think
that when you don't have a child it
seems very attractive and in a lot of
ways it is if it's your dream to have a
child but you also like have to
compromise a lot of your own life so I
feel like it really depends on where you
stand and what your mindset is if you
would like to have a child obviously
some people since they're young they
want to have a child and you know they
want they want to be a stay-at-home wife
and you know they want the family life
and stuff but I feel like nowadays a lot
of women are also like you know what to
be honest I have so many dreams and
goals for myself and if a child would
come in the picture it's going to be
more difficult and I also don't want to
you know
be there less for my child because the
minute you put your career first for
example for myself if I'm a singer and
let's say I would go on a tour am I
going to drop my child with a nanny 24 7
because that child is not going to be
happy to see me 10 minutes a day reading
her a book or reading him a book like
that's not what parenting is so it's all
these factors come into play
um and I've been a nanny I've seen it I
used to Nanny for a billionaire family
and the parents literally sometimes
would leave for like four weeks and then
the child is with a nanny for 24 7 and
the child calls the nanny mummy so I
feel like you know it's it's very hard
and I you know when people say to me I
don't want children I think a lot of
people judge them but because I'm a
nanny I've seen how much of a pressure
people that shouldn't have kids have
kids exactly and then for them for them
a child is like a Prada bag it's like
sick I can put my um I can put my money
when I die I can give my money to a
child but at the end of the day you've
been with your child for like 10 that's
it you know and then they drag their
children to like all these events and
they act like they're the great mom and
it's like babes you weren't here the
whole day and they're like oh yeah she's
done this at school and then the most
funny thing is that my old Nanny
children would be like mum You're just
showing off you're never here and I
would be like
or they would be to people like do you
miss your mama they were like no all she
does is party and wear funky clothes I
was like Oh my days that kid is six so
it's like that's six yeah yeah wow so
and that's also a thing children are
highly intuitive like they know you know
that's why children you know when
children really gravitate towards like
certain people 100 and to some people
they don't it's because they feel safe
with certain people they talk things
yeah exactly so yeah I think I think you
can be happy but if it's really your
your dream to have a child and then it
all comes falling down because you can't
have children then it's a different
different convo I guess that's true
um when we go around I also want you
guys to say if you want kids yourself
um so do you want kids yeah yeah I do
you do okay and then you want to go next
so me I I have an eight-year-old I am a
mom okay but I make sure it's very sorry
I have an eight-year-old I am a mom so
but I'm not it wasn't planned I'm not
maternal in that way so I feel like if I
haven't if I didn't have him then like
now couldn't imagine anything different
but then every literally every person
that I said oh I'm having a baby and
they were like
just like it just wasn't it wasn't in
the plan but like I'm not
I make sure my time is very I treat my
job as a job I treat my socializing is
like I did like totally separate as in
like it's not I've never I've never took
anything away from him he has my full
attention at all times he's my priority
at all times so in that sense it's like
from a mum's point of view
like I would have been if you'd asked me
before I had him I'd have been like I
don't know if I'm ever gonna have kids
like it just wasn't in my plan but now
because he's there
like I would not imagine life without
like as my best friend would do oh like
I don't know the bond the bond is just
that like no one can describe it if
you're a mum you feel that but I also
have like best mates that
have said to me like I feel like I'm
just not gonna have kids and then it's
not like they say it as if they're not
going to be happy it's just like it's
just not in their Planet at that moment
but I feel like it's your situation it's
all to do with your relationship and
you're never gonna have a kid in like a
bad
when you're in a bad space unless it's
accidental obviously so I feel like if
you're planning to have kids and you
want to have that from the life where
you're married your kids you settle down
and that's what that's like your dream
you cannot be happy without that because
that's your turn on Vision you want that
so that's what it is whereas some people
don't have that as their dream some
people want to be ambitious and like
build so much more in a career sense
than so it's like what's your priorities
do you want the family life do you want
this life or do you want an in-between
are you ever going to be happy with
either do you feel like you would have
been equally happy if you didn't have a
child
um it's all I don't know that's an odd
question because like I was happy but I
was very young I added my 21. so it's
like 21 what like what what is do I have
really yeah you know what I mean I
didn't know life as I do now whereas I
feel like if I saw myself at 21 I would
have said no I'm not having kids yet
blah blah blah but me at 29 like and
then if if you ask me that and I'll be
like I'm not gonna where I was like turn
it up like I don't know what I would
have I I still live my life we're going
like we do things a lot together like I
don't see I don't see why yes do not be
there for me to not have fun like we go
on dates together everybody would do is
day it's like that's my life partner at
the moment it just does
um in my situation I'm single so no okay
like but it wouldn't not to say that
word for the record would you have more
kids okay yeah okay what about you do
you want kids so I always wanted to be a
young mom
um and then I turned 30 this year and I
actually had like a midlife crisis
because I was like I have no kids I have
no relationship like my career is good
but I want that like old school family
like that love that life and I did get
sad thinking like
I'm not gonna just settle and like have
someone's kid just for the sake of
having a kid like I want the the whole
package
so if I can't have that like am I ever
gonna have kids and I did actually have
a conversation with my mum the other day
and I was like do I need to freeze my ex
and it was like a serious thing because
I was like what if I meet someone in a
couple of years and you know like your
body
you don't know what's going to happen to
it as a woman so it's quite as scary
thing if it's something that you want
mm-hmm
okay what do you think
um I from a personal perspective
do I want kids first of all yes I do one
children of my own
um I think obviously like some of the
ladies have said
um Society pressures women to kind of
think that that's sort of the role to go
down road to go down to have children
have a family be a wife potentially
um and I think especially where you
reach a certain well women anyway are on
a biological clock whether we like it or
not we are and I think that keeps us
some of us up at night knowing that so
um
having
the thought of having children for most
women is obviously a priority for most
of us but obviously you would like most
women would like a relationship a
foundation a family
I think in today's society looking at a
lot of the relationships especially the
ones that are put on platforms and
social media a lot of them seem to be
failing and collapsing so I think no
shame but it's it's real talk so I think
in one hand you want yes yeah you do
want children but at the same time you
don't want to just settle down with
anybody and end up in a worse situation
there are plenty of women out there that
are single moms and are doing a great
job but still have always said they
would have preferred to have done this
with a partner
um so I think it's down to the
individual finding their happiness I
think
like some people feel already it depends
on who you are what you call and classes
happiness because some people's
happiness are traveling exploring
um and some people just free-spirited
and they're interested in other things
other people I have that tunnel vision
of wanting kids in their family so
to answer the question in terms of
happiness it comes it will be obviously
down to the person but I definitely
think that
women should
be selfish in their decisions
so that they're not in predicaments and
allow themselves to be pressured by by
not even just by Society by immediate
people like family and friends how do
you know it's society and not biology uh
you know like we've done some in a
certain way for thousands of years I
think it's a bit of both I think because
we all know that but we're on a
biological clock
we have like we're all thinking the same
thing but also I think
I don't know obviously we have things
like social media where you see people
uploading at certain age that they're
married I've got lots of friends of mine
that have that are engaged or about to
walk down the aisle at the moment and
where you've been socialized to
go to school at a certain age with your
age mates then you go to college at a
certain age with your age mates then you
graduate you get a job
you've been conditioned that at a
certain age you do the same thing as
your age mates when you get to a certain
age and people around you are doing
certain things like getting proposed to
and you're not it kind of does make you
feel a type of way from being completely
real so did that answer your question
yeah okay
um you and then you next that's fine um
I'm not gonna lie I do oh sorry is that
better
I'm not gonna lie I don't want children
and I think when I was younger I used to
how old are you I'm 23. and you don't
want kids around I'm turning 24 next
month yeah I'm 24 and you don't want
kids around I I used to when I was
younger I was like oh maybe if I was
younger you're only 24.
when I was like 19 18 21 whatever I used
to think that maybe um if I met somebody
that really wanted children I might
change my mind and I might be like you
know what maybe one kid but as I'm
getting the older I'm getting the more I
hear about Festival pregnancy secondly
raising the child second like it takes
up so much of your life and maybe I'm
selfish maybe I'm not I don't know but
at this point in my life I think to
myself I'm like do I genuinely want to
raise a kid no okay I don't I like
children as well that's the funny part I
love children if my friends had kids
imma be the [ __ ] Auntie that's
[ __ ] so I mean I'm gonna spend money
on you but to have my own child I'm
bringing and 24 7 I'm not doing the
sleepless nights how would you think
about being like 55 and childless
as long as me and my babies are
traveling having a good time I'm not
going to have children okay I'm not
gonna lie okay
um and then what about you I think it
depends on what type of person you are
so if one of them people depends on
other people to be happy like you rely
on other people's happiness for your
happiness You're Gonna Want Kids to make
you happy like I've got friends who have
got black kids that shine and stuff like
that and I've got friends who can't have
kids but all they want is a kid but I
know if they have that kid it's going to
make them happy so I think it depends on
your own person or who you are whether
you want kids on our own whether it
depends if what brings you happiness
really I think so some people's
happiness as kids some people's it's not
some people's traveling do you know what
I mean so to me it don't really matter
I want kids I want two kids and I'm done
as many of you know you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and demonetized on a
on and please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible